hey Canada
it's your first ever bachelor at Canada
will you accept this rose yes Jasmine
Lorimer we do accept your rose the 27
year old BC model is about to start an
epic journey to find her happily ever
after in front of millions of Canadians
and a TV crew no pressure I've been in
front of the camera a lot and now I
think I'm pretty pretty well-versed and
Canada's new it girl is ready to bring
the drama which is reality TV must
coming on to last season that was the
best thing that couldn't happen for me
there are a lot of crazy dramatic
moments and I think there's actually
moves that I don't even know about yet
so this will be also new for me when I
watch it but yeah there's a lot of drama
and you can't have a bachelor franchise
without this cue the waterworks an
annoying crier I hope but I definitely
feel a lot and so there there are some
tears that are shed so there's drama
there's tears and according to Jasmine a
ton of real moments on set I think what
surprised me the most is just how much
real emotion gets involved and and I
surprised myself with how much I've felt
because I feel like I learned a lot
about myself through this entire
experience it's really crazy no real the
whole entire thing is and I think that a
lot of the guys were taken off guard too
speaking of those guys Jasmine was
tight-lipped about who won over her
heart but she did tell us there are a
few eligible bachelors she'd be happy to
hand out her final rose to Justin Bieber
would get a rose because he's hot I
would give Prince Harry Rose he's a
handsome gentleman I would give Chad a
rose just for him to entertain me on a
daily basis